Identification this is session three with FAITH BANDLER
and Carolyn Craig recorded in Sydney on Friday night of May one thousand nine hundred seven
and the take begins in about ten seconds time and of identifications aside one. FACE.
How old were you when you decided to leave home. It's too long to remember but I think it for I was about ninety.
Me eighteen. And I went to perspire.
And I was only there for a very short time I spent a lot of time at my grandmother's
but I was only there for a very short time before nine thirty. Now in September of ninety eight thirty nine and.
I remember the night was declared. I didn't mean much to me I thought well it's over there and I'm here.
Although I knew that it would happen. Because Hitler had marched in. Austria. Czechoslovakia. And Poland.
And I knew that the talks that Chamberlain to head with Hitler wasn't worth the paper they were recorded or. I somehow.
Expected it. And yet I was still surprised I didn't know and I didn't even think I suppose.
How it would affect us all in. Australia. But only a short time passed before people we're joining now.
Didn't seem very long at all. And the young me and I would say main certainly older than me but still very young.
In their twenty's. Like twenty's and thirty's. After a few months were beginning to join after course the Tweed.
Where I was born. Wren very deeply in my veins and I would go back often once a month.
Perhaps And each time I'd go there. I'd ask about a certain person. And they'd say Oh he's enlisted and where he is.
And they were particularly women
and gays who were nurses they were then their first postings of course was in the Middle East.
And later of course increase. Can I ask you how you felt as a young woman when you had that board broken.
Well a lot of young people were very excited because life would change for they made no way particularly the people
around where I was blown because life was pretty monotonous and then all of a sudden you have a war
and you see good looking blokes in uniforms around the streets and there they appear free as a bird in the air
and we went crazy about them. So I felt I did. Feel that way. I think. I I didn't have a fear that.
I wasn't excited about it is some people who are. There was a big very big change coming to this very isolated country.
And it was hard to tell how. Most of us would react. For quite some months. But then I recall that it in my opinion.
My brother eighty was the second eldest in march and rally. To me and. I've come to say goodbye my unit is about to go.
Why are there no where. And so I said goodbye to him was no grief.
Because I expressed automatically expected him to come back.
That's how you thought at the early part of the war before the Japanese became involved in the.
It was you automatically thought that everyone would come back. I did. And so was it good bye to him.
Well later we learned that he was sent to Singapore. And Singapore fail. And he was interned by the Japanese.
And then put to work on the runway. And then finally in. Forty three. I think it for. My mother had he done.
And she was he had very very very very many years later many years later when the war was over
and those who survived the Burma. Came home. One by the name of Sullivan.
Friend of our families said No no he didn't do very he was well. Together with a group.
Who didn't respond quickly enough from orders from the Japanese and they were just learned up and shot. So. You know.
That news came through to me when I was in a place called one in New South Wales
and it didn't have a deep souring impact on me because
but I've seen we were picking up the newspaper each day not to read about in order to hear. But to read off.
How many thousands had lost their lives in we were in or a ball in.
The Wood death of a beautiful men and women the thousands.
So my brother's death didn't have the impact on me that it had on my sisters and my mother for some reason or other.
It wasn't until the war was over. Finally over.
We're dancing in the streets that that loss hit me that I wouldn't see him again. But.
I was born at the end of the First World for. And there were people around who.
Photographs of their husbands and brothers and uncles.
Sometimes whole families almost Australian families were wiped out in the first world war
and only twenty years that passed and we were involved in. And I had a friend. Who had a daughter twin.
And one some of us a left turn and or captain in the Army and the other was a squadron leader in the Air Force.
And within a week to week she had news that both had been killed. So.
It was at that stage the war was beginning to have an impact on me.
Too many had gone and had not come back too many had gone to the bottom of the ocean
and too many had on the Burma railway. And I was beginning to think his life.
I thought about this very deeply the other day. When I read or later in the Herald from a rabbi.
And he said when people were being sent to the concentration camps in Germany.
First they sent the Communists he was but he wasn't one. So why should it be. In the trade you know he wasn't one.
So why should he care. And so it went on until they began to sing in the church people.
And he ended up spending same and he isn't in a nutty concentration camp. And you know why.
We were cut off from that kind of thing we have no idea what was going on with Europe.
We didn't know that million millions had died in this life came. And perhaps lighten the impact. You know why.
Because we were entering. On the terrible brutality of the Japanese.
Faith you were part of the Women's Land Army in this time what. When did you join up and what prompted you to do that.
When you know in nineteen fourteen.
Many people most people whom I knew felt I had to get up and bloody will do something
or was it Japanese would take Australia. And I remember very well the night when I was in the city.
And I got the ten o'clock boat her went up. And I heard what sounded like. Yes but they were deaf.
Depth charges being dropped to destroy the Japanese submarine set in.
Coming up and that now I see it's very very fit in my mind.
And so the next morning I said the very next moment he landed my sister
and I went into place where the recruitment center world.
And I recall the officer there by the name of Mrs Johnson who says oh why do you want to go into the land you know very
discouraging. And so we've made up our minds which sister. Kath buses to care.
And to so I guess it's the fact that the Japanese had bought. And we were told they knew that.
People put out and the submarine came very close to that ferry I was on.
That helped me make up my mind
but you see me were thinking as I was thinking we can't afford not to get into something.
It's here it's right here in Australia.
So to begin with the land was the cruelest of all and all I'm sure because we had to provide our own working class.
And we've also villian close to the first twelve months and packing a suitcase with the various necessities
and going up to Central Station and there was an army of the most elegant women all going off to work on the land.
And it was the officer in charge. She had a uniform on she had actually. One of the forces are forgotten which one.
Very able and beautiful home and very compassionate very loving very firm.
So she got us all together on Central Station. And.
Those days you had to travel while I was steam trains but you had to travel and work was if you were civilian
and what was known as the dock boxes.
You know that were just too long in each little compartment and you looked at each other like that.
And of course a very wealthy were always able if not to bribe a good seat or. Get into another carriage but.
Mainly they were kept from soldiers or people in uniform as I said so.
I even Pickering the office said Come on girls and you blow a whistle and just in the east L.A. Going to women would.
Most magnificent do beautifully manicured nails.
Great make up picking up this cases and getting into the dog boxes and we set off for you. And the first year.
We pick there twenty five of us. And we were some of the very early recruits and we got two young and he said Well.
When we arrived from all the far was came to the station and count the mayor came with a local band
and I've just off the train. And of course the pharmacy is for just flapping that I had never seen such a glass.
But I think they also thought his hands take my cherries off the tree. But I have photographs of our right. S.
Here we were taken off with right.
Ceremony to be bedded down in the local showground in a huge pavilion with nothing other than a Catholic apparently yes
which we had to take and fill up with straw and not another thing. Some army blankets. Fortunately the war.
They'd installed a number of shares. So it was in the middle somewhere you see you pick in November.
So we all went into this huge massive hole. It was the exhibition hall for the local show you see and.
Here we were there were already women. So you all in that pavilion a space would have been a bit maybe thirty five.
I couldn't believe what I was. You know women were looking for coaching. And then we showered and settled in. Which.
Then we were told we have to go. To the dining room across the way like across the field. So we went over.
And I've never had an experience like this although I spent some time in a college with my sister where we ate like in
large groups but this was different.
All of these people looked so different and I didn't have a bloody thing in common.
Except to do something for the war effort. And I said. And people who are looking for I can recall.
Who'd come from very wealthy background. When looking for time on their linen table Nick. And the second.
It was nothing they got in the queue.
They used pemmican they used to like for the a party each no trouble at all without exception.
Nobody complained and I'm sure of the back of thinking of the men at the front and what they were putting up with
and what they were going through. Nobody complained. Because who is land on a huge range of activities.
What sort of things were you involved in it was.
It was it may need working at young in the fruit picking all with their other activities as well.
Now it wasn't really because when. One would be sent to where a season was ready for harvesting.
As we were said to young. And by.
Either way each morning the farmers would come in their trucks and pick us up
and you see see woman getting into the trucks like workers. But we picked the cherry crop layer and then.
We were all split a bad name would become very friendly with each other.
Like there was a beautiful musician who played the violin and a beautiful painting.
And these beautiful hands were used to pick the fruit. And from their. Death and.
Together with four or six others forgotten. Were asked if we would go and harvest tomatoes and asparagus in better.
And we were permitted a few days' leave before going to bed. Well still in civvy clothes of course.
So we come to Sydney and we kind of blow and claimed three towns away typically cherries and we get on the train
and go to the next fly so we would have to better.
And that was quite an experience half and I got on the train and we set off and we were told quote.
We would be made the matron at the railway station whose name was Mrs missing. Very close to us it was emu. Anyhow.
We crossed the Blue Mountains and went down in the cities of the plains. As we stepped off the platform.
A woman dressed in. Crape to a beautiful crape pink suit and. A blue hat with Fables. And. All. But it hanging loosely.
Came up and said Welcome girls. I'm the officer Mrs missing. And.
Anyhow she said I'm sure you're feeling hungry so we'll go to the chills. And have some lunch.
Now I'd heard of the reputation of the Chelsea the restaurant.
That during the war when we couldn't get everything was by coupon mate everything.
They they could have scones and cream. The whole works.
So they were you know stuff on the black market but she said I'll take it.
We'll go to the Chelsea in at lunch and I thought that was lovely.
Because you know we've been eating off these two plates for a few weeks and eating stew and what have you.
So I thought someone. She's got a car when she's come along. And she carried law suit case for me.
And we went to hosts trough. And there was a pile of horse having a drink. Standing there.
Patiently waiting for us with a spring cat. And she hopped up into that spring cart very early.
She had two little boxes one for kept to sit on and one for me to sit on. And with a beautiful pink suit and.
Said Come on Dolly pull the horse up and off we went to the Chelsea down the Main Street.
It was wonderful and true and we were going to be billeted Where is she says.
Didn't I tell you what it quote is it's at Mount. Isn't it. Stewart's former residence meant nothing to me.
I had forgotten about that I knew that was where blacks lost and went with and Jamerson
but never thought of the steward's as early settlers the early settlers.
Well we get into this spring cart and off we go about four miles out from town
and up on the Hill is a huge grey castle. She turns to the magnificent driveway.
From right from the bottom little although I. May just stick castle and asked her to succeed. She said.
Yours is just a stupid cow so when they began to give us a street.
She took us in to the master bedroom and said they saw you better. Already there were women there and.
We were treated so well. Never forget it but she said in the morning girls.
You won't be picking asparagus you need to get a little practice in bending the back. So you'll go wanted to matter.
And there's. You have to cross the McQuarrie she said and the farmer is on the other side of the muck already.
But there is a flying fox. Flying Fox I thought flying fox.
Well I remembered flying foxes that had to be kept out of Africa tree said.
Flying Fox Well we didn't ask any more questions and the next morning three of us went down the drive
and crossed the paddock and came to the McQuarrie river and only other side was a tomato page.
And sure enough there was a flying fox. So wait. The idea was to put your kit on your.
Back and you put two feet on one.
Why hang on to the end with another hand pulling the rope that takes you across the river.
And we had to do this every morning every afternoon. So I wouldn't use the flying fox.
And so we picked the matter say for a long time.
The interesting thing about it was that really beautiful relationship developed between so many of the women
and the farmers. And some of the women married married the sons of all the bachelor families.
But if you ask me what I did to begin with. Certainly I've worked on the cabbage cutting cabbage.
Cutting to matters and asparagus. But after all of that you see over in Iraq. January and you pick fruit.
Not so much better. Stone fruit but whatever was there was always apples of course.
And then when that finished the pruning of the stone tree fruit has got to be down.
And that is really essentially a big strong man's job. But we got stuck into it.
You know you use twenty foot lead to get to the very top of the tree
and the tree would have to be shaped beautifully and trimmed to perfection
and I had had some lessons in printing plant so didn't trouble me who flew much. And then after you proved we proved.
We had to rake up the prunings have them in huge piles in between the rows of trees and then learn them.
Well I had a beautiful boys. And he wrote poetry and he knew him. And he for the most beautiful.
So he said well one day tomorrow we'll will you know the pruning limbs stuff we pruned. And I said you're right here.
How do you do it he said well come them or not. Show you.
So I'm going to and they reinforced me had a big draft horse and cart
and what you did was for the cuttings into the car to see and the. You went along the road.
You didn't get too much because that the danger would be the four I would get away from you.
Well lo and behold he said have you got the idea and I said yes. OK. So he left me on my own.
And I made the terrible mistake of taking the horse to face the wind. And so what happened.
I had to find going nicely and everything was going beautifully you know.
Feeling this I am with the cuttings and then I could smell him.
And the horse's tail was on fire because the wind had blown it back over the R. and Cat.
And fortunately I had collapsed. And I rushed to the horse and just grabbed it with my hands.
I put the flame out and if. I've never forgotten and put it in the horses. Pretty to something for.
It was the horse all right and well you're right horse didn't flick an upper. Most thought I was crazy.
So after that few days later came said well if I think you may.
You have really done a good job in many horses still there but I wondered if you'd be do a bit of irrigating now
and I said Of course I would and I had no idea whatsoever that irrigating meant hopping in the tractor.
And going up between the rows so that when they turned irrigation on the water.
It just flowed on and the trees watered heavily. There are no trouble. I had no idea.
So I turned up next morning and he had the tractor all first and tractors I called
and he said well you turn in these things and I said will always measure affect I have and he said I'll show you.
So he hopped up on this new day that I say yes sure.
So I hopped up and I did those things up and back and took the tractor along and he's a lovely deep trenchers.
He got in the car went to town to have a stroller and I took this thing into.
The ground was just too soft and I thought the harder I accelerate the sooner I'll get out of this
but what happened by the time came came.
The wheels of the tractor were almost covered with the sand that I blew up in pressing the excess. Land Army.
I had good to and. And it had better.
There were good times because well there were times
when there was a lot of satisfaction you so all the fruit you picked and sometimes if it were raining.
You'd go into the cane rain came that fruit into huge containers and know that it was going directly to the troops
and all of a. It was going to the troops all the fruit and all the vegetables.
So there was a great sense of satisfaction. And you mentioned bad times and they were bad. But the times when.
From Sydney someone heard right. And we've heard. And then would leave go.
All the way to mourn about to see how many more.
And all of those young men who man I used to go dancing with on a Friday or Saturday night
and they weren't coming back. They were dated. And so one had to come to terms with that.
Of course the terrible thing about war. And I realise this more and more each day. Is that it teaches you to hate.
And to this very day. It's hard for me. To forgive the Japanese for their brutality.
Just for the Jewish people and the soldiers Australian soldiers who went into your.
Men in particular to forgive that you have mountains and it's nearly fifty years and this is destructive for.